[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i just spilled on me all right happy
friday america
so how's your civil war going huh i know
it's crazy out there i nearly got hit by
a cannonball
it's good to see brian stelter found
work
[Laughter]
call me brian
but once again let's look at what the
media defines as harm versus what real
harm is you probably didn't hear about
the machete attack in new york two days
ago
that's right i said machete who knew we
live in the brazilian rainforest
but there was a machete attack in new
york and get this it was a repeat
machete attack by a repeat machete
attacker who had been arrested many
times including for attacking people
with you'll never guess
that's right machetes
she also attacked people with bear spray
which is only supposed to be used on
bret bear
he actually likes it
pervert but the psycho must be wondering
what's it gotta take to get arrested in
new york she must be getting machete
elbow for christ's sake
so days after being released this young
black woman was out on the street again
and attacked an older black doorman not
much of a story of course because well
the variables are all wrong she's not
extreme maggie
and besides jail cells are for steve
bannon and guys who dress as vikings at
the capitol
and how about the feed who shot and
killed four people in memphis and then
smiled like it was his high school
yearbook photo and he had just been
voted class clown
this ghoul was also a repeat offender
he'd been previously charged with
attempted murder but that was downgraded
so he's back on the street faster than
hunter biden's last date
but i guess we'd hear more about it if
he was extreme maggot but he's not
and besides like alec baldwin they'll
just blame the gun
too soon
because remember the real war is between
maga and democracy you know it's like
when jaws made people scared of sharks
when easy bake ovens were a far greater
threat
wow
i must be old
am i really older than the audience
oh god i'm going to need some relief
factor
anyway
you see what happened in las vegas huge
story a notable investigative journalist
which rules out kill mead
this journalist was found stabbed to
death now this is the kind of story that
enrages journalists one of their own
gets taken out for speaking truth to
power he'd been actively writing about
vegas corruption and was stabbed to
death by someone he pissed off you know
it sounds like a scene right out of
casino or a cat's honeymoon
but he helped catch his own killer the
killer's dna was found under the
victim's fingernails so i guess this is
what biden was warning us about these
extreme mega types lashing out at our
media and our democratic leaders
except well the accused killer is
actually a democratic leader a democrat
politician in vegas
so no wonder the media abandoned the
story like it was ashley biden's diary
a lot of important tips on bathing in
there
that's vague enough
right
now if you read the headlines or skim
the articles you'd never know the killer
is a democrat which i totally understand
because whoever writes the article has
to figure that the killer will probably
be out of jail in mere months and we
know how the killer feels about
journalists who write bad things about
him
so really there's no need to rub his
nose in it over being a democrat just
call him an
official now you think a republican
would get the same treatment if he
murdered someone
they're way ahead of me
you're right but you knew that
fact is the paper that the dead
journalist worked on was one of the few
republican-owned papers so this attack
was not just against one reporter but an
entire staff a paper and the media
doesn't give
because they aren't on the same team so
they erase the political affiliation
like it was a biological woman
now
making crime
funny it's hard now if the situation
which situation were reversed
then you would know the headline
republican murders brave journalist
sorry no it would be extreme magga
murders journalists women and minorities
hit hardest experts blame trump and
climate change
and it would be woven into the fantasy
of this so-called maga civil war
it would be the initial volley of the
brewing battle even joe biden would have
his pants at half-mast
patriotic
but since the story doesn't fit that
criteria it heads to oblivion like
crystal pepsi and dan rather
there's no political capital to be
gained when a journalist is murdered by
a democrat
and now income's obama who will
gleefully ignore all this mayhem like he
did with isis he'll also say the threat
to this country isn't crime it's people
who don't vote for democrats whose
policies lead to more crime
it's not all the senseless murders you
see
it's the complaints about the senseless
murders
so remember when the media was happily
hoodwinked by justice millet they
embraced the hoax despite its absurdity
well it's happening again but at a far
greater scale the media now portrays the
country as a colossal smilet just
waiting to be attacked by imaginary
racists and red hats it's a hoax like
the others but that won't stop them
smelled has become the unofficial
spiritual leader of the democratic party
by giving the party a road map that runs
right through maggot country stoking
fear through fabrication of an enemy so
now we're living in a war of the world's
version of hate crime hoaxes and the
media will always defend the hoax saying
well it's true somewhere if not here and
while that's happening
this is happening in illinois another
state gets rid of no cash bail because
you know it's been a rousing success
everywhere else
here's what that means
it abolishes cash bail for almost every
offense
this includes
but isn't limited to kidnapping armed
robbery second-degree murder
drug induced homicide aggravated dui
threatening a public official and
aggravated fleeing and eluding
offenders released on electronic
monitoring have to be in violation for
48 hours before law enforcement can act
they could almost drive to alaska
before we can even look for them
it denies victims or constitutional
rights
and keep this in mind businesses and
homeowners officers will no longer be
able to remove trespassers from your
resident
residents or your businesses
someone could decide to live in your
shed
and all we can do is give them a ticket
you have to decide what level of force
is required to remove them
and whether or not it's legal
thank god i don't own a shed
i think that's the lesson we all learned
here but it is amazing a killer can
drive to alaska before cops can even
look for him i hope jamie lissau has
some spare bedrooms
it's the only person i know who lives in
alaska besides sarah palin
and we don't talk much
sarah and i were you know
now political leaders they have one job
to maintain order so you can live a
somewhat secure life and here they
reject it under the assumption that such
laws don't work for certain people which
is racist but then they call you racist
for complaining about it so what's this
mean well while the democrats chase down
phantoms in red hat you'll see more
violence and more death from actual
living breathing criminals and it proves
that what happens in vegas won't always
stay in vegas because all the dems do is
bet on red
what
welcome
tonight's yes
seize our overall favorite guest as in
guests that wears overalls
that was funny guys buck's business
anchor david mcdowell
please believe us his name is jesus the
great social scientist in youtube
extraordinaire hotep jesus
he may be the only person better off
wearing a barrel
don't you remember those cartoons guys
the barrel
wow i'm old founder of
theloftusparty.com
and in for cat
[Laughter]
he's so bright he gets a tan by looking
in the mirror co-host of fox and friends
first todd pyro
i want to go to you first michael
because as a homeless person
you must be terrified living on the
streets when you see the constant
recidivism because if somebody come out
and take your blanket and then get a
rest and then come back out and then
take your pants it's that's what makes
it totally scary yes
repeat machete lady
horrible i don't know bear spray too she
knows she's doing the blind then whack
yeah yeah so she's been thinking about
it i don't like any of it no you don't
no no people need to daring a daring
statement
right and like and you see what's coming
with uh chicago and all of illinois yeah
it's like they're just planning on a
live action role play of the purge right
yeah you know you can practically hear
the people at u-haul counting the money
well we need more people more people are
leaving more people are leaving sign
them up sign them up
can't this be stopped
they're going to have to stop it they
really are and it hurts everybody i i
even feel bad for the illegal immigrants
coming to america when they find out
they're going to chicago yes right
you know what that the mayor said that
you're the mayor lightfoot said that
it's cruel and unusual punishment for
them to come to chicago can you imagine
you leave venezuela you're marching
through the jungle you survive snake
attacks and then there's drug dealers
trying to keep you and then machete
people you go across the desert with no
water you finally get to texas you're
like we made it to the land of milk and
honey you're going to chicago yes
oh my god i'd be like isn't it isn't
that room on the new york bus i could
get in the overhead i can i can scrunch
it we're tiny people we're tiny
all right hotep great to see you first
time i met you hey it's a pleasure to
meet you i feel like i know you because
i watch so many of your podcasts and
your streaming and all that stuff it's
great what do you make of this current
situation you talk about this stuff all
the time don lemon once said that the
greatest terror threat in america is
white men
and usually he doesn't tell the truth
but at that point he was right because
that white man looks just like joe biden
don't you love though that he's kind of
being he's now the law and order
president
i love that he's it seems to be working
for him when was he not the law and
ordered president
i got uncle's in jail right now because
of him
but now he's disowned that part of him
he's changed yeah you know with the
socialists
what they like to do is create chaos
and chaos brings necessity necessity
yeah so they can come in and he can lock
everybody up he's going to bring out
like an international police is what i
believe but if you think he's gotten
started you have seen nothing yet well
what do you what do you so what what's
the next step are you are you weaving a
conspiracy i am
[Laughter]
i really believe that they want to make
things so destitute and so dangerous
that they'll have to you know they said
fund the police right he finally said it
yeah they're going to 10x that they're
going to bring them in from other
countries whatnot and turn us into a
complete police state i don't listen to
alex jones though well
you know he speaks some sense
i'm going to buy a big canister of grain
seeds
you don't see the commercials where they
sell a big can but you don't have a shed
so where are you keeping the damn thing
you need a [ __ ] you need a shed
[Applause]
i hate everybody
except women except you todd what do you
make of this what are your thoughts i
know you've been up since two in the
morning i don't know where i am again as
always um on the on the illinois story i
love how the illinois state legislature
is like
we think chicago's too safe we want it
to be like the big apple so what can we
do again bail reform nobody in jail for
any amount of time but on the front of
the media which is the marketing art for
the democratic party they know that the
only way republicans lose this election
is if they don't focus on crime and the
economy those are the two things
republicans need to focus on republicans
getting a little distracted taking the
bait from the democrats on extreme mag
abortion and stuff like that but the
democrat-run media knows
if they do stories about crime it puts
crime in the ether and with the two
months leading up to the election they
know they can't afford that or democrats
get whooped in the terms yeah this is a
political and it seems to be working in
the sense that i mean like well it's
easy for it to work because the media's
you know again amplifying it what do you
think degen uh that you don't need to
watch television to know how bad it is
in our nation cities because you can see
it when you walk out of your front door
i mean we've been experiencing this
since the the riots of
2020. um number one if there's ever
anybody in your garage or your laundry
room just give me a call
i'll get them out yeah just with a look
yeah yeah a smirk yeah
um i've been carrying a hammer
in my purse which my father told me he
was like you better have some picture
hangers in that purse with you in case
you get stopped for hitting somebody up
the head with it that's true
carry a painting with you right at all
times and then pull out the hammer and
smack them yeah look no but like a
little you need some picture hangers and
a little photo because you need problem
you need a reason to be carrying the
hammer with you
[Music]
why are you it's i'm i'm just serious
hilarious i'm dead serious i love
thinking i
when i walk out of the house but just a
reminder that the real threat to the
republic is donald trump with the files
and the folders and the documents he
took to his house think of the hell he
will bring upon this nation with paper
cuts they sting
they get sore what if they get infected
that's horrible
by the way
how dare
paper cuts hurt more than anything
right there it's because you're so
you're you've got to decide
this area is very sensitive that's how
you touch things so when you when you
when you run it along a piece of paper
it's just it's worse than getting
stabbed in the eye
by the way i wonder if your if your
dad's logic works with a nail gun like
if you had a nail gun because then you
could fire the nails but you could say
yeah i just
you carry some molding okay around in
your purse
or your backpack yes and say i'm going
to and do an ins a kitchen installation
or say you're a member of the village
people dress as a construction worker
i'm i'm a big i'm a bit confused yeah
i'm a bit confused yeah so if somebody's
hiding in your shed and the police can't
remove him
but i remove him yeah and i'm not going
to say how yeah but i remove him
do i go to jail yes that's the weirdest
thing because like like unless you have
picture hangers
you're hanging a picture in your shed
hang a picture in your shed problem
solved
then rent it out to the homeless person
call it a tiny home
what a scam that is
tiny home
oh or as you call that's not for married
people
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else